la journée a été également marquée par
un rite inévitable à chaque changement
de majorité la passation des pouvoirs
entre les ministres elle s'est déroulée
il faut le dire dans un bon climat à
l'image de la soirée électorale les uns
et les autres ont été dignes parfois
même chaleureux simone veil a été si
bien accueillis par trois hommes à la
fois les trois hommes qu'elle remplace
relancer car yves barbe des passations
de pouvoir comme ça ça mérite le
déplacement d'abord parce qu'une femme
qui succède à trois hommes c'est une
belle affiche
ensuite parce qu'une alternance dans la
bonne humeur ça surprend on les croyait
adversaires on les découvre bons émis
échange de compliments d'abord les
partants nominations honorent ce
ministère bonne nouvelle il y aura un
ministre de la ville et deuxième bonne
nouvelle
madame veil en 88 je me félicitait
d'avoir éventuellement à être dans votre
gouvernement madame ça n'a pas été le
cas
on comprendra que en 93 ce ne soit pas
possible je ne désespère pas
bref un grand moment d'émotion question
calais répondre simone veil réponse
encore des compliments je souhaite que
nous puissions continuer à travailler
que votre expérience que vous avez
acquises ici mais aussi très longuement
auparavant puisse me servir et que quand
il s'agit de ce secteur
je crois qu'on dépasse souvent des
clivages idéologiques pour arriver à
saisir sa réalité humaine c'est derrière
résultats à la sortie on en venait
presque à faire un rêve un peu fou et si
droite et gauche se tendaient la main
mais très vite chacun est parti de son
côté des rêves comme ça en général ça ne
dure que ce que durent les roses